and with Kanye owning parlor then it  maybe won't be necessarily like a right  wing social media you know what I mean  it might be actually just apolitical  people his fans that have no interest or  aren't even right-wing you know so it  could be a big deal if black Twitter  moves over to parlor then exactly yeah  if black Twitter leaves and Twitter's  over yeah 100 and that would make it not  that I mean we see these alternative  social media sites yes we're glad they  exist but you know it's all right  Wingers that's always my issue it's like  why I'm not on gab and all these things  it's like I don't want to just talk to  people who yeah I would take the hate  over just blindness you can't troll yeah  you can't fight you can't troll